researchers from Bogota Botanical Garden
are exploring a very special ecosystem
at an elevation of more than 3,000
meters lies the world of the pot Ramos a
landscape that exists only in South
America for botanist Mauricio Diaz
granado's it's truly an El Dorado son
suprima men tell us this area is so rich
biodiversity the variety is in the
details it's in every square centimeter
and it's different from automotive potty
mouth there are not 5,000 different
plant species here vamos plants of the
genus s pelicia are especially
noticeable these giant rosette plants
are the focus of the scientists research
because they're hugely important for
flora fauna interaction the botanists
have established that global warming is
threatening these plants they're
increasingly subject to insect
infestation and they're dying off
semente i dos dos que haces las plantas
tienen a meager our clients try to adapt
and my great but here they have nowhere
else to go because they can't go any
higher that means that plants that grow
high up in the mountains are gradually
becoming extinct 16 the lush vegetation
in the pot Ramos has an amazing ability
to store water acting like a giant
sponge the plants absorb moisture from
the clouds and release it again slowly
into the ecosystem like a natural
reservoir the wetlands of the Andes feed
streams and rivers in the dry season
right down to Bogota they're one of the
most important sources of drinking water
in Colombia but the paramos are under
threat los campesinos tienen una
práctica relative it's common practice
for farmers to
burn the paramos so they can use them as
grazing land afterwards animal husbandry
changes the soil in the countryside
which means the paramos can't store as
much water so lol horizontal páramo a
team from the Botanical Garden is trying
to convince the farmers of the
importance of protecting the environment
this farmer has been given a precise map
of his land for the very first time sawa
linares says it should help him better
protect sensitive areas like springs and
streams lie das poorness estrategia sunt
we need a two-pronged strategy that
takes into account the interests of
farmers but also protects our water
resources equipos aliquots importantes
Colombia's vegetation is extremely rich
in biodiversity researchers are
constantly discovering new plants the
botanists hope their efforts will
convince the local inhabitants how
valuable the pattern most ecosystems are
for all of Colombia
you